bonjour le coup de coeur de l'espace
philippe noiret cette semaine c'est dans
le cadre de la saison jeune public donc
j'en profite pour vous rappeler qu'on
est une saison jeune public avec des
films des cinés goûters et des
spectacles programmés à l'année cette
semaine on a le programme des trésors
plein ma poche qui est un joli programme
d'animations pour les enfants et les
plus grands à partir de 3 ans donc c'est
un programme avec six petits films qui
ont été réalisés par six réalisatrice
talentueuse et donc c'est des histoires
d'entre aide de solidarité avec de
jolies rencontres par exemple la
rencontre d'une baleine et d'un nuage
d'une petite fille et d'un dragon avec
des techniques d'animation très variés
que ce soit de l'aquarelle
du papier découpé par exemple ou encore
du pastel et c'est un programme qui fait
la part belle à la musique
donc voilà c'est l'occasion d'initier
les plus jeunes pour une première séance
de cinéma par exemple et pour voir de
jolis films d'animation très poétique
donc je rappelle que dans le cadre de la
saison jeune public
on fait aussi des ateliers et des
goûters donc n'hésitez pas vous
trouverez ça dans la plaquette de notre
saison culturelle